Beijing says a leaked paper on Germany's
New China strategy is a throwback to
Cold War times
earlier this week German media had
reported details on how Berlin wants to
deal with a country it calls a
competitor and systemic rival this new
strategy would be a significant shift to
how Germany is approaching China the
reported draft shows that Germany wants
human rights standards to play a major
role in future economic relations that
includes keeping forced labor out of
Supply chains Berlin also warns of
lopsided investment in recent years
China has been buying up companies and
infrastructure abroad while blocking
similar access within its own borders
foreign
most recent example of that Chinese
State shipping giant Costco buying a
steak at a freight terminal in the port
of Hamburg after Hefty political
wrangling Costco was allowed to acquire
a 4 24.9 stake in the terminal critics
say China could use the second largest
port in Europe as a political weapon
Chancellor love Schultz overruled
opposition from six Coalition allies and
Ministries and National Intelligence
service and allowed the move to move
forward it's a tough call China is the
port of
the port of hamburg's most important
trading partner accounting for nearly 30
percent of container throughput it
provides thousands of jobs but calls for
Less dependence on China are growing
amid that I spoke to excellent matern
Port of Hamburg marketing CEO and I
asked him how concerned he was that the
German government is warning Chinese
investment in ports around the world
could be used for the military
I mean this is something where we have
to be concerned about in general but
looking into the example which we had in
in Hamburg or which we have in Hamburg
having a minor share investment in one
of the terminals of the smallest
terminal in the port of Hamburg that
doesn't refer to any kind of military
topics or or even infrastructure topics
this is something which is pretty normal
around the world in ports and in
international trade as well as the
shipping lines are
acting on an economical basis and they
have to secure the possibility in the
ports for themselves so it's a pretty
normal exercise what we are looking at
here Germany wants to put its relations
with China on a new footing China
obviously is Germany's biggest trade
partner but it is a showing a more
assertive stance on the the world stage
so is recalibrating this relationship
the right step
of course I mean we are calling for that
since since years now because it's much
better for us being an international
trade to have some kind of guidelines in
order to to act on on the international
floor and that's what we are waiting for
since since ages now and so we are
looking forward to have this kind of
guideline from the government and uh and
this is what what we would like to have
but on the other hand we should be aware
of that Europe and and Germany in in
full is pretty much uh dependent on
international trade and especially as
well on the trade between China and
Europe and we should
to at least take that in mind preparing
this kind of strategy for future
um relationships and of course the
Hamburg Port is heavily depending on
trade with China on this this strategy
that's apparently in the works is to
contain among other things regular
stress tests for companies with
significant exposure to China how do you
expect Hamburg ports business with
Chinese logistics companies like Costco
to develop amid these plans
I mean we we have uh been in contact or
we have CostCo as a client in Hamburg
since 40 years now so we are pretty much
aware of who we are talking to to whom
we are talking to and uh we have a very
um uh relationship which is very
trustful to be honest and uh we are
talking not politics here we are talking
about handling containers which are
heavily needed to to run the the German
and European economy apparently so we
are trying to to fulfill a duty which is
which is handling of containers at the
end of the day not more and uh and so we
are pretty reluctant about any kind of
stress tests with uh Chinese company
because the companies are uh on the duty
to fulfill their Duty in in terms of
handling containers transporting doing
Logistics
trade with China is the most important
business of the Hamburg Port now higher
costs to be less dependent on one big
customer need to be taking into account
the chancellor says when it comes to
doing future business what's your take
on that
I mean we are we of course we have more
than 30 percent or one third of all the
cargo being handled in the port of
Hamburg is related to China coming from
China going to China Import and Export
so but not all the cargo which is being
handled in the port of Hamburg is being
transported by Chinese companies so
there are a lot of other ship owners and
liner shipping companies which are
transporting these cargo and these
containers so we are not relying on on
Costco for example so there is others
like hypogloid like MSC or CMA CGM which
are deeply involved in transport of all
the containers worldwide it's an
international business it's
International Trade so we are not
dependent in this respect on on One
customer
actually my turn head of Port of Hamburg
marketing thank you for your thoughts